et voici l'interview pinceau de celui
qui n'en veut plus fred forest en fred
forest tué pied noir gêne et un mascara
cette mort et tu travaillais aux ptt à
la frontière marocaine et en kabylie est
ce que c'est ça qui t'a donné le tu vois
je sais tu es bien renseigné un qui m'a
donné le goût c'est le groupe
d'électronique et le goût dit roddick
alors à l'époque c'était un peu bizarre
caïques blattner mais disons que j'ai eu
un contact direct avec la communication
comme ça à la frontière marocaine alors
en 63 tu vu en france il a en métropole
10 ans plus tôt et c'est là que tu es
rentré aux ptt tu as travaillé au
centrale paris un terreau archives c'est
ça et que c'est devant une descente
quatre policiers ouais ça après si tu as
été formidable d'ailleurs parce que il y
avait tous ces petits points rouges qui
s'allumaient sur les bouquets bottes et
d'ailleurs
remarquez que quand la vidéo ici on
television le feuilleton s'arrêter tous
allumés j'hésite intéressant de voir la
relation entre un événement télévisuel
sociale et la traduction sur le plan
visuel fred forest était là j'avais
avait une émotion extraordinaire
[Applaudissements]
ça n'a pas empêché quand même dans un
premier temps de faire la peinture
surréaliste
au départ c'était un peu choqué par les
surréalistes pitt a quand même fait de
la peinture se réaliser pourquoi ce qui
s'est passé c'est quand 69
on a donné une église gothique à tours
on t'a dit exposer vos toiles là dedans
et tout est à dix points du tout moi je
veux mettre de la lumière je veux mettre
de la musique en face à était parti dans
autre chose quand j'ai vu le lieu ça
transcende et ça m'a donné l'idée qu'il
fallait faire un environnement et j'ai
conçue justement ces vieilles pierres et
je me suis dit il faut mettre là qui
reprenait bien pires qui représente le
symbole du passé je me suis dit il faut
ici concentrer le savoir du présent
c'est à dire des ordinateurs des
consoles de son etc à 72 tu fais le tu
achètes un espace non je peux faits
donnée après deux ans de négociations
serrées au parlement sera publicitaire
un espace de 150 centimètres carrés
c'est ça c'est ça
dans lequel les gens pouvaient
s'exprimer en grand les ressorts
paraître c'est une nouveau type jobs et
l'équipe de l'oeuvre 150 centimètres
carrés et je proposerai aux gens de
s'exprimer soit par l'écriture soit par
le dessin et je m'engage et à faire une
exposition de toutes les réponses mais
sans
deux sélections s'étaient la globalité
des réponses que j'ai explosé à
plusieurs reprises c'est la naissance du
du collectif d'art sociologique de fred
forest vous ou
non pas trop récent les deux points qui
restaient oui alors tu as fait 60
secondes de silence à la télé aussi
savait me demande comment j'ai pu faire
ça démontre la wii c'est ce qu'on le
fasse à dakar a lancé allons-y
on peut faire bien vu c'est que j'aime
faire une oeuvre d'art tu vois voilà tu
sais ça a du sens finalement voilà parce
qu'on est un peu saturé par
l'information on est passif on est là si
on reçoit l'information et tout d'un
coup en faisant une rupture comme ça en
quelque sorte je tends à restituer les
gens à eux mêmes et à remplir pour ainsi
dire alors ça soit remplie par la
télévision
c'est parce qu'une part toute modestie
une forme de zen qui passerait par les
mass médias la télévision elle j'aime
bien la meilleure partie de l'émission
alors après tu as fait un truc encore
plus fou 75 à exposer madame soleil ce
qui fait dire à l'aiea les faits en
vidant à l'époque juste un paradis maman
alors ça pourquoi c'est pas simplement
le goût de la provocation
madame soleil c'est un phénomène
médiatique tout d'un coup tout le mythe
de l'astrologie qu'ils rencontrent les
moyens de communication modernes et
sacré le phénomène madame soleil alors
été sympa l'a accepté d'en devenir dans
le musée ou à donner des consultations
tous les jours souza des de velours
rouge
alors après en 76 ya eu le fameux m²
artistes alors là tu as voulu si j'ai
bien compris je voulu montrer les
liaisons qui existait entre la
spéculation immobilière et la
spéculation artistique
myers a été interdit par la police oui
il ya eu des tas de péripéties en fait
je voulais faire une oeuvre qui soit une
oeuvre information qui est pas de
matérialité qu'on puisse pas touchée est
la gageure c'était de dire je vais faire
un événement qui va faire émerger dans
les médias cette critique sur la
spéculation en faisant un amalgame
justement de la spéculation dans le
marché de l'art et celle de l'immobilier
et puis tu dois de souvenirs vont à
l'époque j'avais réussi mon coup parce
que ça a été vraiment du délire dans
tous les médias
donc tu avais une page dans façade ah
oui je vis une page dans l'interface
alger avait proposé beaucoup de choses à
passage avait travaillé avec façade très
souvent alors après tu es passé du
collectif d'art sociologique à
l'esthétique de la communication c'est à
dire que finalement tu dis que armstrong
posant le pied sur la lune
c'est plus important que mona lisa
pratiquement oui c'est à dire c'est
autre chose je pense qu'un nouveau type
de d'émotion qui peut être généré
aujourd'hui est que quand des millions
de téléspectateurs ont vu justement posé
le pied de l'homme sur la lune la lune
qui est à un objet mythique et que
c'était le sens la sensation le
sentiment du partage qui était donné par
ces moyens de communication de masse qui
en quelque sorte abolisse le temps et
l'espace et qui nous donne la conscience
qu'on partage un tueuse à quelque chose
avec les autres alors voir l'art
sociologique avait fait son temps parce
que sa venue après mai 68 on remettait
les choses en question s'est-elle
question demande la société critiques
etc
mais aujourd'hui ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de voir comment ces moyens
technologiques note à d'ici d'être avec
les computer les robots les nations qui
se marient le minitel voilà ça c'est de
la faire essayer de faire ses lacets
finalement toucher à l'imaginaire donner
du plaisir
projeté les gens dans d'autres univers
on peut le faire sans doute on l'a fait
pendant des siècles avec la peinture à
la sculpture et aujourd'hui on peut le
faire avec le téléphone avec les
ordinateurs avec les faces est malade il
visitait modère t à léopold au moins
deux mois d'août 89 l'a dernièrement un
état fait un truc s'appelait rituel pour
nuits blanches
oui alors c'était la cadrature du cercle
polaire alors c'est quoi ce truc rare
mais sans référence aussi avec mon
histoire du mètre carré
c'est à dire que
j'ai été démontrée parce que ça les
téléspectateurs de sa fin ils doivent le
savoir
en fait moi j'en ai la preuve
aujourd'hui le cercle polaire n'est pas
un cerf c'est un carré c'est un carré de
1 mètre sur un mètre donc j'ai monté une
expédition qui était jusqu'au pôle nord
le mètre carré artistique effectivement
à l'agropole exactement et tout au long
de ce cheminement qui m'a mené jusqu'au
cercle polaire
j'ai effectué des mesures à l'aide de
différents appareils technologiques ces
mesures au jour le jour je n'ai passé
sur saint quentinois par la télématique
jusqu'au jour je suis arrivée au cercle
polaire où les appareils ont clignoté et
j'ai vu que mes hypothèses de départ
était juste malheureusement j'avais
oublié d'enclencher le bouton qui a
enregistré ça et je suis le seul
aujourd'hui à savoir que le cercle
polaire est un charisme croire sur
parole chez l'homme cette veine là à
fait d'accord voilà voilà parce qu'on
est dans dans l'affabulation on est dans
la fiction
qu'est ce que tu fais au goethe institut
jusqu'au 24 novembre
alors je présente que ce qu'on appelle
une installation une sculpture vidéo il
ya une exposition dont le thème est le
cycle écologique et donc je présente une
sculpture qui est en quelque sorte le
mariage du rhin et de la scène mais
qu'est ce que tu fais avec moscou la par
téléphone a alors ça ça c'est le 22
novembre prochain
ben en allant moscou j'ai connu des
artistes dont un musicien qui à ma
demande va créer une oeuvre musicale qui
va tendre à se substituer à la marche
militaire qui serait donc une ballade
dont le thème est balad pour changement
de régime donc le 22 novembre à la
galerie dont 10 depuis on entendra ce
musicien faire cette création mondiale
par téléphone depuis les théâtres
vassiliev est là dans la galerie
j'exposerai aussi tout un environnement
avec des portraits de gorbatchev des
lignes mais installé
selon un itinéraire qui n'est pas
forcément porte d'aix
c'était influencé parquet par exemple
marcel duchamp bien entendu mais
quelqu'un qui pour moi le sommet c'est
yves klein et je pense que si qui
pleurent aujourd'hui était parmi nous et
bien travaillerait avec ses moyens
électroniques parce que hitler a été le
premier qui nous apparaît justement de
la dématérialisation de l'art est cassée
de traduire les forces de l'énergie la
sensation du vide j'ai rien inventer
quand je faisais un blanc dans le
journal le monde klein l'avait déjà fait
dans la galerie des risques clairs 10
mois à l'époque où l'art c'était de la
production d'objets on peut vendre ces
objets oui mais toi comment tu gagnes du
pognon à l'envers je suis professeur
voilà oui je sais que j'en vois pas ma
fille mais tout je suis professeur à
l'école nationale d'art cergy d'une part
où j'enseigne la vidéo et janssen aux
communications l'actualité des médias
mais je suis aussi un professeur à la
sorbonne où j'ai un cours est assez
muller / ar communications nouvelles
technologies à ton avis ça sert à quoi
ce que tu fais ça sert à quoi est ce que
tu fais ça sert à rêver ça sert à
réfléchir ça donne du plaisir et puis ça
sert à faire fonctionner les télévisions
les radios les journaux et thierry
ardisson
des corrections de ne rien rater de
inhabituel abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus